bitterly cold weather that is not just
unpleasant it is downright dangerous it
is expected to feel get this like it is
below zero for more than 80 million
people today some areas could feel like
temperatures of 50 degrees below zero
plus there's snow in the north and ice
in the South Downing trees and causing
all kinds of problems our Lilia Luciano
is at a warming Center in Saint Paul
Minnesota Lilia good morning
good morning to you David it is 12
degrees below zero here it doesn't just
feel like it it is that cold we're in
front of a warming Center one of a few
that the county has opened up especially
this one for men they say it's almost at
capacity with about 88 people they're
not turning anyone away if it is this
cold they expect a lot of people and
this as the Northeast is bracing for
potentially life-threatening conditions
for all of us this will be an
inconvenience if you're staying outside
this is life or death in Boston homeless
shelters are full but no one will be
turned away the Polar Plunge has begun
the city is expected to see temperatures
Free Fall well below freezing by noon
some schools make the tough choice to
close Friday in the dangerous cold we
could get frostbite
while in Western New York an overnight
blast of Arctic air Unleashed wind gusts
of more than 40 miles an hour in
whiteout conditions the bone chilling
temperatures in the Northeast come as
the South begins to feel some relief for
the first time in days after
temperatures finally Rose above freezing
at least 11 people across Texas Oklahoma
and Arkansas were killed during the
storms most in car wrecks due to
ice-covered roads and hundreds of
thousands of customers across the region
are still without power we started a
fireplace put some pots on the gas
burning stove and that's about all we
have
the south is also not out of the woods
yet but up north in places where
temperatures have dipped under 30
degrees below zero the National Weather
Service warns that it could take less
than 10 minutes for frostbite to set in
Gail
Lilia thank you that is certainly good
advice stay inside if you can